[Music]
[Applause]
this is what I'm trying to do but was
exciting about it for me is essentially
they showed that to me I think a few
days ago like you this is so amazing
because you know whatever I get to do in
the show ultimately is Shepherd and
amazing character to be holding me to
probably a better person ever version to
me and the sentiment of what that is is
what I think the fiber of what Hawkeye
is at least what I think Hawkeye is this
is a superhero without superpowers and I
can teach someone else how to be the
superhero without superpowers and I
think that's an amazing sentiment to
share the people say because they never
but that means everyone's a damn
superhero to the strength dang superhero
and I think that's fantastic
well thank you so much for hanging out
with us also
you win best entrance of Hall age for
sure
[Applause]
thank you guys
thank you guys read a hot guy [ __ ] out
[Applause]
and by the way we'll explore mortis time
as Ronan in this series hi everyone its
charlie happy comic-con week continues
we have more footage from the Hawkeye
series that's happening during Marvel
phase four so we'll break it down
obviously they gave away a couple of
details during that panel and the
footage that I included at the beginning
of the video but we know a little bit
more about it than that so we're doing
that Avengers end game blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Hawkeye moment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this as you can
see from the big schedule the Hawkeye
series is gonna drop fall like around
October 2021 tail and Marvel phase four
this is the entire Marvel phase four
schedule Kevin Feige did an interview a
little while after the Marvel phase four
panel clarifying what's gonna be during
phase four and what movies he announced
that are gonna be Marvel phase five like
the Fantastic Four x-men the Blade movie
the next Avengers movie whatever
Avengers 5 is going to be so this is
that clip of him talking about it we
debated what we should announce today
should we announce four and five we've
planned them out we've got five years
down the road and I was like I think you
got eleven projects in two years is
plenty so just going by his comments
there's a lot of stuff that they talked
about at that panel that will
technically be Marvel phase 5 but
that'll cover the next five years don't
worry I'll do some follow-up videos on
Marvel phase four Marvel phase five
stuff because there's a lot of big stuff
that we know about that we now know is
going to be Marvel phase five but per
the teaser footage that they dropped
Kevin Feige Jeremy Renner they're going
to be introducing Kate Bishop during the
Hawkeye series so it's not a character
that you've met before it's not gonna be
Hawkeye's daughter Lila Barton from the
beginning of Avengers endgame there were
a lot of people that saw these trailers
and they're like oh wow he called her
Hawkeye good job Hawkeye because she hit
the bull's eye does that mean that she's
going to be the Kate Bishop of the MCU
no it will actually be a character named
Kate Bishop and it will be a version of
comic book Kate Bishop but they'll have
to change a couple things because
Hawkeye in the MCU is very different
from comic book Hawkeye Kevin Feige also
confirms that the Hawkeye series will
cover some more of his time as Ronan
meaning that that will pie be flashbacks
so all the Ronan stuff they do will
cover the time
after the end of Avengers infinity war
Thanos is snap and before Black Widow
goes to pick him up in Tokyo
midway through Avengers endgame remember
during Avengers endgame when war machine
is talking to Black Widow after the five
years later time John talking about how
Hawkeye is leaving this path of bodies
we just spot him in Mexico were pretty
sure that is his handiwork he's been
spotted heading to Tokyo this is a
little taste of the stuff that will get
in those Hawkeye Ronan flashbacks so the
series itself will take place in present
day after the end of Avengers endgame so
this is 2023 Hawkeye would not be
surprised if they use some of the events
of the snap in the blip back as
motivation for a cape bishops Hawkeye
character to become a vigilante they're
a couple of events in her backstory and
obviously they will tell her backstory
during the series but maybe also using
some flashbacks because it's only gonna
be six to eight episodes because they're
adapting the fraction Hawkeye run where
he trains Cape Bishop to officially
become his successor and take the
Hawkeye name that was actually after
Kate Bishop had been introduced into the
Marvel comics for quite a while she'd
already been with the Young Avengers at
that point so just expect a couple minor
changes to her origin story but the
reason why she initially decided to
become the Hawkeye character er become a
vigilante and then take the Hawkeye name
is because she was from a really wealthy
family but her father was tied up in all
this shady mafia stuff so she followed
him one day trying to learn more about
what was going on and got caught up and
and she almost found out getting killed
but the Avengers saved the day she was
particularly impressed with Hawkeye when
he was rescuing her so that was sort of
the beginning of her love for the
Hawkeye character she became a big
Hawkeye fan girl later she eventually
gets the crap beat out of her she
decides to toughen up and learn martial
arts so that she can defend herself and
then eventually finds herself working
with the young Avengers but all this
time she still idealizes the Hawkeye
character so eventually Captain America
says you should take the Hawkeye name
then he starts to officially work with
her and train her to be a real
replacement for Hawkeye like look you're
kind of good you have some skills but we
need to hone this if you're really going
to take my name and become the new
Hawkeye Kevin Feige also revealed that
all the Disney Plus Avengers series will
tie in with the movies and crossover in
really important ways really good
example of that is the Scarlet Witch
vision show which is going to build up
to the plot of Doctor Strange too
because
Darla's which is going to be in that
movie teaming up with dr. strange the
title of that is called dr. strange in
the multiverse of madness clearly laying
groundwork for mutants x-men Fantastic
Four characters to come into the MCU but
what does that mean about the Hawkeye
series what movie is the Hawkeye series
going to cross over with and the answer
is the next Avengers movie which Kevin
Feige didn't talk about at this panel
but we know is going to happen didn't
you think it was weird how Kevin Feige
announced eleven projects in the next
two years for Marvel phase four but no
Avengers 5 he talked about Fantastic
Four he talked about an x-men movie but
no Avengers 5 that's because all this
stuff on the schedule here like I said
is everything from Marvel phase 4 and
it's only the next two years mainly that
Marvel phase four will only last for two
years very short timespan there was a
lot of confusion in my last Marvel video
when I tried to explain that a lot of
people were operating under the
assumption that Marvel phase four would
last for way longer than two years in
they just announced a couple projects
and the rest of it will be announced at
d23 like here's the rest of Marvel phase
four but per that clip with Kevin Feige
that's not the case so all that other
stuff
Avengers 5 Fantastic Four x-men that's
gonna be Marvel phase 5 in phase 4 and
phase 5 together will basically be the
next 5 years worth of Marvel movies and
TV shows so very clearly Hawkeye is
going to meet Kate Bishop during the
Hawkeye series trained her to be his
successor and officially take the
Hawkeye name then she'll go on to
crossover and maybe like a small cameo
before the next Avengers movie but then
show up in Avengers 5 the reason why I
say cameo in other people's movies
during Marvel phase 5 is just because
typically Avengers movies happen at the
end of phases but they haven't said what
year Avengers 5 is going to come out so
it's still speculation at that point
next big question you're all asking is
what's gonna happen to Jeremy Renner's
Clint Barton Hawkeye after the Hawkeye
series permanent Hawkeye retirement to
his farm will a cameo again in future
Avengers movies will a cameo during a
young Avengers movie because there is
talk about them doing a young Avengers
movie what about showing up in other
people's solo movies there's a rumor
that he's cameo in the Black Widow movie
because that's set during the past and
they're explaining all the Budapest
history that the two of them have been
talking about for the last couple of
Avengers movies early prediction most
likely
Aereo is that he'll retire to his farm
to be with his family and just stay
there until they want to use him in
another Marvel movie like Avengers
secret wars or if they want him to cameo
during the Young Avengers movie
eventually old man Hawkeye pulling the
bow back out even though Jeremy Renner
this is kind of funny is still very
young he's about 10 to 15 years older
than Chris Evans Scarlett Johansson so
he is one of the more senior Avengers
actors but he's still younger than Mark
Ruffalo and Mark Ruffalo is gonna
continue to be the Hulk
during Marvel phase four Marvel phase 5
but here's a quick rundown of which
actors are not going to come back
anytime soon so you have Iron Man
probably not gonna come back in any of
the next couple of movies during Marvel
phase four maybe maybe a message of some
sort or recording during Avengers 5 in
Marvel phase 5 he's one of the only
actors whose face does not appear on
this Marvel what if she because all the
Avengers and MCU actors are coming back
to voice their characters it's an
animated TV show so it's a lot easier
for them to come back and cameo during
the episodes Chris Evans Captain America
is also out for the time being but he is
coming back for what-if episodes he's
gonna come back for an episode of
what-if to play Steve Rogers it's gonna
take place back in the 1940s I'll talk
about the plot of that when we do more
what-if videos Black Widow is also out
in present-day movies but she's possibly
back in flashbacks obviously the Black
Widow movie is set during the past all
of the other original Avengers are
coming back though Thor the Hulk Hawkeye
all coming back in present day is still
alive and well I know a lot of people
have also wondered about ant-man and the
wasp 3 that is gonna be now Marvel phase
5 anything that you know is happening or
that they're probably going to do but is
not on this schedule and wasn't
mentioned at the big panel is probably a
Marvel phase 5 movie everybody let me
know in the comments though what you're
most excited for during Marvel phase 4
it what'll happen is is I have a Black
Widow trailer video that I'm doing
there's a whole bunch of stuff from the
Marvel panel I'll do a new blade video
but congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big Marvel video Luc
Downey please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my Marvel comic con panel
that Fantastic Four x-men teaser and
click here for my spider-man far from
home Fantastic Four post credits scene
video thank you so much for watching
everyone
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]